Vineyards as far as the eye can see
they nestled on the edges of the forest
facing the Sun
the German cyclists wine route runs
right through the vineyards the hundred
kilometer route combines natural beauty
culture and culinary highlights the
plots is a region with a distinct local
cuisine every small village boasts
vineyards and traditional fair Dinah's
Heim has a very special reputation the
dynasty myrrh hope hotel and restaurant
is located right on the market square
it's been known internationally ever
since former German Chancellor Helmut
Kohl invited fellow politicians to dine
here the region's hearty meat dishes are
legendary here they're served with a
modern twist in the cuisine in the files
has become a bit more refined during the
last 15 years we have lots of good
restaurants and it's always worth making
it to dine in the region people from the
fights used to travel across to France
to dine now the people from there come
here
our next stop is humba a perfect place
to explore the region's turbulent past
perched high above the village is
Hambach castle built in the 11th century
it belonged to Bavaria and to France and
was destroyed and rebuilt several times
it's been an imperial castle a Bishop's
residence an archive and a ruin nowadays
it houses a museum that documents an
important chapter in German history the
humbucker Fest in May 1832 30,000 people
marched to the castle demanding basic
rights freedom and peace among nations
over a century later in 1949 their
demands formed the basis for the basic
law Germany's Constitution
drafted in eight months the basic law
was passed by the parliamentary Council
in bomb we followed the German wine
route southwards these vines are more
than 400 years old and still supply
grapes they belong to the village of
Volta under Leechburg
most villages in the floods were
devastated in the 17th century war of
succession voltage elite work was an
exception
so this winemaking village is a gem with
buildings almost as old as the vines we
stopped to look at Lupe's her Villa when
the plots still belong to Bavaria King
Luke fig the first had a summer
residence built here its balcony offers
a panoramic view over the vineyards
wined is the heart and soul of the
region and an important economic factor
the floods is the world's largest
Riesling grape growing area ambitious
young vintners are helping wines from
the plods to greater popularity and
esteem I hope that at some stage will be
recognized internationally as a
first-rate wine growing region I hope
many vintners will take part and
continue to exploit and expand the
potential here so we'll get a bit better
each year so make yourself statistic I
don't know funny bumping our trip along
the German wine route ends at the German
wine gate in spigen as soon as you pass
through it you're in France